(bomb explodes)
- [Evan] How to delight customers.
My goal is to delight my
own family of customers.
Just like my dad did for his.
Louis Trahan,
Founder of Last Minute Training.
(light music)
Louis Trahan had a problem,
he's in a boring industry.
Louis' company,
Last Minute Training
sells training for office workers.
Most people don't think about
training until they need it
and it's really hard to get people excited
and talking about it.
Most people see training
as a necessary evil,
not something to look forward to.
When was the last time you
went around telling everyone
you know about that amazing Excel training
you just can't wait to take?
Exactly.
But with my help,
Louis realized that he
doesn't really sell training,
he sells the experience
of being delighted.
His one word is delight
and he built his entire
business around it.
He delights his customers by
actually caring about them.
He and his team research
and know more about all the
training options available
than any other competitor,
so he can give the best
recommendations to his clients.
He knows which training providers
deliver the highest quality
training for each subject area,
who is least likely to cancel classes
and who has the best learning
environment for his customers.
He often books people into courses
where he makes less money
because it's the right
thing for the client.
When he interviews new staff members,
he first looks at whether
they have an attitude
of delighting people,
before he looks at their skills,
experience,
or references.
In his marketing,
he shows a picture of his baby son smiling
because he wants people to feel delighted
when they see his ads.
The results,
when I first me Louis
and he joined my mastermind group,
he had just an idea on paper,
it was a pure startup.
Fast forward a few years
and Louis now has an office,
a team,
brand name clients,
sells over 10,000 training classes
and has booked almost
$10,000,000 in business.
He's making money
and making an impact.
So I asked Louis to share
how he found his one word.
(light piano music)
It was over 20 years ago
but I can still remember
it like it was yesterday.
I woke up on Christmas morning,
wondering where dad was.
He was gone because it was cold outside.
I mean really cold,
like 50 below.
And another family needed him
to come fix their broken furnace.
(light music)
He was a furnace repairman
and these were his customers.
Dad always went above and
beyond to help a customer,
even if they were total strangers,
especially on Christmas.
This wasn't the first or
last holiday without him.
Dad hated seeing people suffering.
I could tell you story after story
where he aimed to bring joy and relief
to the people around him in every moment,
often at his own expense or his family's,
and now I understand.
We were all family to him.
Every person.
Now my goal is to delight
my own family of customers,
just like my dad did for his.
I can't help it,
it's ingrained in me,
it's part of my DNA.
And let's be honest,
you probably rarely think
of scheduling training as
a delightful experience.
In reality,
it's probably a huge headache.
(light music)
Most of our clients tell
us they would previously
spend hours and hours researching
and then booking and
managing multiple vendors
for a variety of
different training classes
only to get inadequate
or even canceled classes.
We screen the vendors
and trainers for quality,
making sure we understand your needs
to get you the right training,
plus we negotiate the deal for you.
Our staff can often find you
the right training class in minutes,
where it might take you
days to complete the search
for the right class on your own.
I've built an entire team
made up of people who,
just like my dad,
will bend over backwards to delight you.
It wouldn't matter what
kind of business I'm in,
my number one priority would still be
to delight my customers.
(light music)
(bomb explodes)